Hey guys Matt here for Science or Fiction.
Don’t you just get tired of seeing pseudoscience
plastered all over the internet like it’s
actually true?
Storms triggering earthquakes???
Hahaha that’s so dumb--what a crackpot,
flat earth, non-scientific headline!
What kind of basement blog would --Oh
Can certain weather really cause earthquakes?
Is there such a thing as “earthquake weather?”
CBS SF Bay Area reported: No.
On the other hand, The California Department
of Conservation said… also no, and they
expanded by saying “Earthquake weather”
is a common misconception dating back
to ancient Greece.
Ha, nice job, Socrates.
And the U.S. Geological Survey said earthquakes
are statistically as likely to occur in hot
weather as cold or rainy weather.
So basically no, no, and no.
So I guess that settles it.
Short video this time.
There are NO legitimate sources claiming weather
affects earthquakes...
EXCEPT this New York Times article.
Nature, and Newsweek, and National Geographic?
What's going on?
First, a little middle-school refresher on
earthquakes: Earthquakes are caused when the
slowly moving tectonic plates that cover the
earth shift to the point that the rocks between
them--known as a fault-- break and cause seismic
waves that ripple across the ground, which
we feel as an earthquake.
Now, what about those headlines and the weather
connection?
Well, the New York Times reported that the
sudden plummeting of air pressure--which can
happen when a storm quickly moves in--causes underground water and air to rush toward the surface.
This potentially reduces friction between
tectonic plates, possibly making an earthquake
more likely.
The New York Times points to part of a study done in Taiwan, which is one of the most seismically
active regions in the world.
The researchers found a very strong correlation
between typhoons and tiny, miniature earthquakes
called “slow quakes,” which may have a
role in reducing the grinding pressure between
tectonic plates, you know, like a chaperone
between high schoolers at prom.
Anyway, the pressure from the typhoons appeared to be enough to trigger a fault that was already
under strain, resulting in a tiny slow quake.
In addition a researcher who studied the past
50 years of Taiwan’s weather and earthquake
records, found that earthquakes of a magnitude
6 or higher were 5 times more likely to occur
within 4 years of a major storm.
This is possibly in part because storm-caused
erosion removes pressure from atop faults
and allows the faults to shift faster.
So, weather may actually affect earthquakes.
It’s so crazy that that’s not crazy.
Kind of cool.
Now, it’s important to note that there doesn’t
appear to be more or fewer earthquakes because
of weather.
Weather can only possibly shift the earthquake
timeline a little at most--not nearly enough
to be predictive of future earthquakes.
And these studies so far are not conclusive.
Sorry Socrates.
But if they were, that truly would be groundbreaking.
I stand by this pun.
Now if you’re someone who's unhappy that science is still perfecting how to predict earthquakes,
you may be pleased to watch this video on new methods for predicting volcanic eruptions.
Don’t forget to subscribe before you split,
and be sure to keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.